it's Monday July 13th greetings from
[ __ ] podcast Ville the church
is brought to you by stamps.com listen
everybody's avoiding crowds right now
but if you need to go to the post office
print postage at home and skip the lines
with stamps calm plus you save money on
discounts you can't even get at the post
office and now
stamps.com is working with UPS so you
get discounts up to 62 percent off plain
and simple
me and my wife or me with a [ __ ] line
my wife wouldn't be able to do what she
does if it wasn't for Stamp calm you
skipped the lines you print your own
postage and the mailman picks it up you
can't beat that so right now they got a
special offer for the fridge fit for the
church family you ready grab a pen a
four-week trial plus three postage and a
digital scale where you gonna get that
type of deal no long term commitments or
contracts it's easy go to stamps.com
right now
write it out stamps.com click the
microphone on the top of the homepage
and press in church
stay safe that's all you need to do and
you'll get all the benefits of stamps
calm kick this [ __ ] melius
monday [ __ ]
[Music]
Jim Stanek
welcome to church [ __ ]
beautiful day to be alive Monday
whatever happened last week tell them to
go [ __ ] themselves it's a whole new week
get unemployment on the phone they still
ain't picking up what's happening you
bad [ __ ] talk to me I need some of that
tape you have any of that CBD tape that
they sell there at the I inhabit but I
do not have because I'm starting to play
tennis again Thursday with my girls that
I haven't played with me I would have
liked just because I love that idea so I
mean I'll just get it 20% off seriously
I'm gonna get it right off because that
sounds like a brilliant idea to me some
people don't know Vicky Bob Langer
she's number one a dear friend of mine
we go back 20 years number two she was a
finalist on America's Got Talent
yeah and number three if you want to get
married she'll [ __ ] marry she's got
her own [ __ ] Church what's the
name of it it's called it's called
wedding chapel to go wedding yeah Lou
and I got a van we wrapped it in leopard
and we go anywhere and marry people tiny
little weddings or I could zoom wedding
right now I could zoom anybody all
across the country
mm-hm Vicky boy I'd be there which is a
pity what a [ __ ] he is gone Thanks so
fast Joe you look good you filled up
your life with all this great stuff for
me too
it's been it's been fast it's been fun
nobody gave us [ __ ] Vicky you and I are
the two poster child for working not
given until they gave us something I
remember one time I was seeing a table
read with you and it was at a tall
building with a beautiful view and you
said you know Bob my leg it's it's not
the shows it's the Greyhound bus you
take to the shows and that has been like
my favorite thing that's always been
your head right the truth yeah because
it's always it's the stuff around the
shows how much fun that we have in La
Jolla it's so much fun so much fun in
fact we should go back into an alley
show there so what I hear next weekend
they're gonna start doing shows in the
alley in that piss-filled alley can you
imagine okay they put the bathrooms in
the store now so there's a four-seater
to Fort Cedars so people have been
pissing less and less plus it's been
closed for three years so the smell is
probably not too bad but I think we
should do it I mean you know I I don't
mind
it's just put some pot around and I
probably won't even smell it at all if
that's
a huge parking lot back there they will
allow us to use them no not the Von's no
they will never would no it's the alley
it's the [ __ ] how many people you're
gonna put me 40 that's not bad I could
do it I could work with that they love
it I can work with this outside I could
work there like there's no money I'm
like I don't care there's no need to
solve it means no paying well I don't
want to get any through your [ __ ]
head I ever get my [ __ ] unemployment
I don't want to screw that up like it's
ever gonna happen but you know so I
think it'd be fun we should do it what
made you start counting I just literally
was in the bathroom and there was there
was a trash can in my bathroom and it
said comedy class sandy shore paulie's
sister teaches comedy picked it up out
of the trash can and I said I'm gonna
take a comedy class no it's 40 and I'm
like I had no idea I only been in one
comedy club in my life The Comedy Store
Hollywood one time and net I just never
thought of anything just just how the
inkling that I should do this because I
was always trying to make people laugh
because I was a fat kid so anyway that's
what I did and I walked in and Sandia
just uh just uh translated an alien
dictionary because she'd been abducted
on the ship for about a year right
before that so I knew I'd found a home
and but she was really good to me she
said she said you were a special gift
and she nobody ever said anything nice
to me about anything I ever did so I'm
always grateful to her for that you know
it was the class it was I was like like
nine weeks I remember Bobby Lee was in
the in the in the in the you know back
then if you took Sandy's class even
forever you were an [ __ ] so people in
that class was looked upon as an [ __ ]
but but I'm I'm still glad that that's
what I did because the guys were in that
room where we really they become really
good friends of mine and I wouldn't have
known that there was a Mike how long do
we go back with Bobby Yeah right right
he was walking around quiet when we met
he was like yeah he was he was still
bowing away madam is she he was bowing
when he walked into the comedy club I'm
like we got the [ __ ] bomb
non-bonding yeah you know we saw him
blow up I still talk to shame yes yes
yes I still talk to you know there was
just so many great people down there you
know that was going down there when I
was snorting kilos yeah and I would walk
in and go Lou what's the story they go
guys the bartender and I tell the bar
time that make the call right before I
went up on stage for the first show and
when I walked off the [ __ ] package
was there it was like you can't really
you know both places were madness yeah
but the madness was different at both
places yeah
what about tonight Lou remembers this I
get down there and loses to me Joey we
got a call there's some people they're
gonna come hurt you oh yeah do you
remember that phys all that [ __ ] and I
was like no worries I took all the I
took all the balls off the pool table I
put him in my pockets and I put him in
strategic places around La Hoya I got a
big kitchen knife from the redhead and I
planted it upside down in the plant
outside I was gonna cut these
[ __ ] I took all the pool sticks
and I took him out so in case they came
in there was pool sticks I only knew
where they were so I could hit them I
set this [ __ ] up like [ __ ] Rambo you
understand like it's like right now my
house is so booby-trapped I upgraded the
alarm certain things that you're gonna
go for because I'm a thief so I know the
out so I walked around my house with the
[ __ ] alarm guy and he learned an hour
like he was like I need to hang out more
with you yeah I got this vent here I
want a camera on there and a [ __ ]
Center on there
why because I would go through these all
the time this is easy this is easy and
if you got a kilo of coke I got a
sledgehammer slash Doolittle sledges
like this for [ __ ] two hours so I
know why I broke this la jolla calmly
store up like I was going to war he I
took a couple knives so I put them
around in case I had a Thrall on me I
was out of my mind is this why they
don't have a pool table anymore luckily
it wasn't a pool table was it bumper
pool okay that is why they don't know
so we never return the balls I had those
balls everywhere they had a hooded
sweater and I had a ball of each pocket
oh I was [ __ ] gone big that night
because there was like three or four of
them it was him another and now would
dear friends now I mean physically of
friends he's I don't know if he's still
doing comedy he's the other guy
disappeared it was really brilliant
the other kid was gonna be a really good
comic he had the mind of a great comic I
don't know what happened to him drugs
abuse something happened to him there
were nice kids they got mad at me
because I told him not to touch the
microphone yeah at the Comedy Store I go
don't touch it cuz the wires gonna break
sure enough the guy goes up then takes
it like the gorilla the wire breaks now
we got to do a 20-minute interval during
the [ __ ] three minutes show for open
mic is really because you didn't want to
be a polite open [ __ ] mic
we told you not to touch the [ __ ]
microphone then he went outside and
started getting loud with me we pushed
each other and he started threatening me
and calling me and I get to a higher one
then everybody's like listen bro he's
coming by go I got this handled man I
don't know who was featuring for me I
don't remember who the [ __ ] that was and
I was sitting outside in between shows
and I heard them they were in the car
I'm sitting in little booth across the
Chinese sushi restaurant I don't know
what's there now another Chinese citizen
last time I went I went to the Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu school next door oh this is
great that guy that is still he's great
he's a grace though he mails me he's a
great man in La Jolla I forget what a
rather read then there was something
like that right now he's a great teacher
showed me sign control
he was great so I'm sitting out there
I'm waiting for these jerk-offs I look
up Vicki and I see them making them what
the left onto whoa you know I'm from La
Jolla and I step up behind the plant I
got the knife in case I gotta throw it
they had water pistol they showed up to
a [ __ ] gangsters house with water
pistols so as they were gonna pull the
water pistols out I took the [ __ ]
white ball and I just swung it at that
car and it sounded like a bomb went off
boom that like a key almost tipped it
over cheap Japanese guys that almost
dipped it over totaled and they flew off
within 20 minutes [ __ ] Tom he was
calling me the cops just called me
what's going on I go they can't show it
the [ __ ] with me and this is what
happens
never again that they bother me just
that noise they told a bomb had gone off
they took off they burned rubber after
that that's so dope you know I see you I
think of Marilyn
yeah me too I think a man with you once
a week since I talked to you the other
day I thought I was doing a British
podcast the other day and they were
saying what happens if you don't this is
a sad part auditions but they what
happens you don't have health insurance
in America I go well if they put you in
a [ __ ] closet and that's they say
goodbye you know I just remember how how
wet much it would have been great if we
could have if Marilyn could have had
good health care and and it was so awful
but she was the best funniest most
wonderful I would be at a light with her
only be white people we don't people
crossing in front of us and she goes he
does it look like the kind of guy that
would twist your nipples doesn't he look
like that kind of guy that which her
nipples dingy
come on yeah man he so does yeah I love
it too
you know and I just miss her so and I
would call her and she he go hold on one
second and we talk for a minute then
she's like hold on I'm gonna suck your
dick you like it like an eagle you like
shiny women all right Joey yeah suck it
suck it play with it did you come yet
and you're hearing this on the phone
she'd be making sucks sounds out of a
giant 64 ounce scurvy and then she
shipped a Slurpee yeah it was it was an
experience when she died a little piece
of me when I found
that was one of the other reasons why I
stopped going on economy still because
she always told me about the store how
it was like she really I met her at the
Laugh Factory for the Latino laugh fest
yeah showcase I wasn't even living here
and she approached me and she goes Mitzi
see you yeah yeah like I'm like no and
she's like that's your first stop after
here yeah like she goes hold on she
might not be there tonight it's
Wednesday night wait till you come down
next time I walk into Mitzi's oh good
she needs to see awesome and Marilyn was
also the first person ever to call me
out of my drug use and when she called
me out on it I was done with the drug a
week later Wow I was 13 years ago she's
been dead yeah it's hard to believe she
died November 3rd with Ramos birthday
November 3rd 19 2007 yeah I quit coke
maybe a week after oh because of Howard
no it was a little she died November
whatever but a month before that she got
the cancer in April yeah
and they brought a home in August
because they know yeah what what we're
gonna heat have a year for it's no good
so they were having little parties for
her yeah and I would go on Sundays and
one Sunday was just me and her and she
was telling me that when she was gonna
beat this disease she had to talk with
John and she wasn't gonna curse onstage
anymore
oh she cuz I'm not gonna curse onstage
anymore because God doesn't want me to
do this if he beats his cancer I'm not
cursing on stage no more and that that
same breath like she was like you know
like when somebody's struggling to talk
and breaches I could get over this I
told god him I won't curse on stage on
one she looked at me and she goes and
God wants you to stop doing coke Joey
well you have to stop you have to take
care of yourself you don't want to be
Who I am right now and everything sunk
yeah just I know this was it I knew she
loved me this wasn't some [ __ ] fake
counselor this wasn't a guy at the hot
The Improv that wants to be cool and do
an intervention this was
from a place of love if it was anybody
else I would have smacked him at that
time
I was feeling and I looked at and I said
you're right
I think it's time to make do something
with God you know I think that is
absolutely true that she she knew that
and she wanted you to know that the
other part though it makes me sad
because you know I feel like she was
always some so brilliant but she was so
that much of ahead of her time and
people kept telling her not to swear not
to be body you know not to be what to be
like you know - you're too dirty and it
was like they were shaming her
constantly shaming or shaming or shaming
her but she knew in her heart that that
was not bad it was good what she was
doing was very good that's why I went
after that producer and that [ __ ]
producer because I change a lot and then
he came around yeah he tried to help
Marilyn out but he was given a you know
nothing compared to what the guy was
really made but to hear that she
internalized that so much that on her
you know bargaining days with God
that she bargained that you know that
she took their side against her own self
that's how much indoctrination she got
from the industry not just him but from
everybody
Mitsy never shut her down but everyone
else did you're not gonna get on this
showcase over and over again and and
because she was so much ahead of her
time that's all what she's what she did
then is being done now on a [ __ ]
every show I'm gonna tell you a very sad
story I've never told anybody is Marilyn
wasn't the best-looking woman in the
world but she had a great heart you look
like a little china doll Indian dollar
girl Indian doll she was chubby and she
wore well she was proud of it I was
before I was giggling I was thinking
over a joke I like all you guys and walk
around with muscles benchpress me
[ __ ] yeah I miss you said let
me sit on your face trying to get me off
your face let's see how strong you
really are you bets 200 pounds
benchpress me like she you remember what
she would do the the the home depot joke
would she go I went I went a few when
it's like damn II lift up in the shower
so I hire
like three guys from Home Depot lift me
up lick mine let me so when she was sick
Betsy Salkind I decided instead of
bringing her flowers we each chip in
forty bucks we got a guy from Home Depot
so we bring this guy to the hospital and
she was in in Los Angeles now we
realized that all these people are
taking these like people from Home Depot
and getting their organs so now we're
bringing this guy over to the hospital
and we're trying to say in English to
him his name was on Mario we're good
Oh Mario we're not gonna take your
organs our friend is sick she has it's
joke about men from Home Depot so we're
taking you as for our friend but we're
not gonna take your organs we're trying
to convince him that so he doesn't
really know what's going on but he's
such a doll and he comes up to the
hospital with it he's so beautiful
lovely gets in bed with her and lays
there and they talk and it was fantastic
but it was just like I was with her one
night and it was a Sunday night she was
rocking in those days she really had the
store down yeah it's a it's a gift once
you have the store down it takes a
couple of years you know you do well on
the road then to get the store down as a
different story they had her at the
rights mine for Brian Holtzman
yeah behind me you know get the [ __ ]
outta [ __ ] quickly she was satiated and
then one night we were there and this is
what I think she broke this is why I'm
giving this to young comics as a piece
of advice we were sitting there and Lisa
Lampanelli was on the stage at the time
you know but no Lisa was but she was in
there with her whoever was pushing her
in the beginning I love Lisa Lampanelli
no I'm just telling you what I saw on
stage and that Lisa was heavy
she had on like men's pants like a
sloppy white shirt she was big mm-hmm
she get off you see Lisa now and Lisa 10
years was different than the lease that
walked into the yummy stuff and Lisa was
up on stage and you know there was like
film people there and you know half the
hollywood was then a Sunday night to see
Lisa Lampanelli
nobody nowhere was it was like a
showcase her agent the manager set up a
man and looked at me and she goes that's
the [ __ ] I've been doing for the last
ten years nobody talks to me mm-hmm and
I member taking her outside and going
listen man doesn't really matter you met
you yet you are but she cuz you see they
don't [ __ ] like me like that was one
of the times she felt very disliked and
she was right yeah she goes at least
laughs no he's up there talking about
black dick didn't ya doing this and that
I've been doing what she was talking
about you suck Filipino dick yeah cuz it
was small Chinese day it was the day
Google's yeah you know I [ __ ] like that
she was saying all that [ __ ] nobody way
before anybody no way before anybody
else it was me her Holtzman we would
like to hide men out you know it is so
weird how there was it's just such a
weird thing about it's just like boom
it's like lightning strikes certain
people why didn't it strike Marilyn and
because though but she was so far ahead
of it so far ahead of it and then Lisa
just got into that sweet spot that
Marilyn had opened up and people I just
you know that and that the thing is like
we just have to come for me it's like
always been about just like Don not
caring just just caring about getting to
do stand-up cuz if I think I just always
expected nothing to happen at least
Vicky I'll expect nothing from this
career yeah I thought if I would be an
extra when I came here if I mind he had
no expectations already that I came here
with a pilot yeah you know I had no
expectations or anything I was just I
knew that I was going month-to-month my
career was six months to six months and
somehow everything always happened every
six months yep I had lines by the TV
show this guy like she got a new agent
that would make you stay and say okay
yeah I'll stay for another six months
right
22 years we'll look at that yeah no wait
and Joey you were ten years younger than
Vicky when she started but it do you
think starting later in life has helped
you
my OS I can't admit like I started at 29
something like that and I felt like all
the open mic over 10 years younger than
I felt out of place so I don't know how
how it affected you guys Vicky go first
it is what it is so for me it's like
because I was a mom I used to drive up
to the comedy store parking lot in
Hollywood and go I'm a mom from Vista
California who's sold carpet for the
last 20 years of my parents shop and I'm
going into the comedy store parking lot
how is this happening and when I get
inside all the people were nice to me
because I wasn't a threat I wasn't like
somebody they wanted to [ __ ] I was just
like a mom brought cake and so I feel
like I had I had a special in because of
my weirdness but you know industry was
like no no no no no even when like the
Comedy Store put me on is like the next
breakout star admits he was so glad my
back so hard no one else and I and I
wasn't the kind of person that would
knock a second time on any door I didn't
I just didn't get that but the book the
thing is it probably would have been
better if I was younger when I was
younger I was catatonic I was I was so
afraid what year did you start um it was
like 1997 okay do my first stand
sacrifice
yeah funny buddy listen to this I want
you do you have a website or anything
yeah it's a biggie barber like comic
want you to follow Vicky bar but I'm
gonna tell you why okay this is what
respect is to women women earned respect
you have to earn respect as a woman at
the Comedy Store
always remember that yes men are gonna
try whatever people gonna bother you but
you know what if you earn your respect
as a woman at the Comedy Store you could
walk in their head [ __ ] hot yeah
Vicky barber like started in 1997 guys
if we're talking about 2020 now that's
23 years but I'm gonna tell you
something that was the most
disheartening thing to me and Vicky's
gonna remember this I got here in 1997
which made me 34 years old I got
criticized so much the cocaine use
didn't help because it made me look 44
you know I'm saying yeah but there was
such a stigma about comics over
25 that it was horrendous
I still remember listening to my biggest
beef I think my biggest thing I did in
this time and I love I love Rick Messina
I love Rick Messina I love we do for the
for the comics he used to cook on
Sundays but Rick Messina is behind the
store one night and I'm like five feet
away Rick Messina and whatever
management would Tim Allen's management
during Harry's management they will also
expect the secular producer of his first
show yeah tool time yeah time whatever
the [ __ ]
so he's the sweetheart of a guy I mean
this is executive producer but I did
show on TV at the comics on a Tuesday
night not tootin not Tuesday Wednesday
cuz Tuesday was Joe Torre night in the
back and yeah they just took over the
store you know the african-americans so
the white people would actually be
scared to come down do you remember
Tuesday's yeah in the original yeah you
wait you would call it ten they're like
we're not open yet we got four people
waiting to start the show we need six
like [ __ ] like that I'm Tuesday nights
you know so now if you want to think
about what's going on back then you got
the word right here but I heard that
[ __ ] tell a woman one night
there was a girl I didn't know uh yeah I
didn't know her I didn't know her
personally I sang at the store she'd
come down and work on Sundays and
Mondays half attractive you know I if
I'd see it today every month yeah yeah
she was talking to Rick you know trying
to [ __ ] work him over for management
or whatever and he said to her I heard
it he goes you know honey your time is
coming past mm-hmm and she goes but I'm
just 32 he goes then I think Holly was
not interested in 3301 right now they're
interested in 25 to 28 so your time is
passed and then they spoke a little
while long and I went home in my cocaine
and next day I woke up on it's all about
I go that was the rudest thing and I
because first off he's making a million
dollars off Drew Carey and all 25 years
old
yeah he's making another million
dollars of tonality he wasn't no 25
years old so why you
they were discouraging us they will
purposely go agents would say I do your
face you're too old for what I'm looking
for what do you mean you know what the
[ __ ] are you man for and then some
people are like yeah you're funny let's
bring your commercial agent Rick Messina
did give me a shot once though and it
was like so awful because it when I said
the holiday when he has that baseball
game in his yard yes what holiday is
that whatever every Sunday because every
Sunday so every it was a big one though
it's like everybody was going and so I
am very very careful about pots
specially back then I hardly ever smoked
it cuz when I was 12 I had to go to
rehab for drugs anyway so I pot affects
me very strongly so it was a Randy Randy
one of the big pot smoking comics
whatever anyway he asked me if I want to
hit I driven myself and everything so I
usually I said yeah I'll take a hit I
took one big hit and it was like all of
a sudden the room was just the I'm
spinning around I was like oh my god
so I had to go to the very top of the
stadium seating all by myself and wait
until I could speak and Rick Messina
comes all the way up all the way to the
top and six next to me and I couldn't
speak I literally couldn't open my mouth
couldn't move I just looked at him like
this it's [ __ ] Rick Messina in my head
I know what I was doing nothing I was
ruining my career my life that this
moment was happening and I was [ __ ]
unable to help myself and I I just
stared at him for like ten minutes and
he really weirdly and they goes huh I go
mm-hmm and I just had the most crazy
crazy crazy face because I was trapped
in my I couldn't I know I've been there
I've been there we start saying stupid
[ __ ] they talking about the moon you
come up the side Vicky you [ __ ]
[ __ ] idiot [ __ ] idiot I do it all
the time still I don't know what people
saying yes I don't know what this saying
I make noises and [ __ ] he probably just
came up to tell me I was too [ __ ] old
anyway but just in case he liked my
comedy that seemed like that mighty way
with that trip up those dare what is it
Ben see you like
the last ten years before America's Got
Talent and how did you get America's Got
Talent
the last ten years before we're pretty
rough because those were the Tommy years
and I got kind of kicked out of the
Comedy Store because he kicked everybody
out that he didn't want around and and
anyway that I always felt like it was
the worst thing that ever happened to me
but on the other hand the terrible
things sometimes turned out to be not
the terrible things because I think I
was taking it for granted and and so
then I had to go around and just do
whatever I could find to do and I was
doing you know just you know like
private fund raisers working in the
clubs in San Diego as much as I could
because I never stopped doing stand-up I
still went up like four or five times a
week
oh yeah I always got the Hoya right and
and so and then I and then I um then I
started that wedding business and that
turned out to be really fun and that
that was great and then I so so and then
I was also doing a really fun show
called Real Housewives of funny
Housewives of Orange County which we had
six seven hundred people every show so
that was like poppin and I was loving
that but then sure Sharon Houston called
me up one day and she goes I'm producing
outside for America's Got Talent
I want you to come out and I go [ __ ] it
are you [ __ ] crazy how was sharise
she's beautiful and great she's really
busy and good she's doing all that
Hollywood producing type stuff and so
I'm like they're not gonna take me
Sharon you're insane she's still
beautiful she's so pretty she could I
haven't seen her it's like she's 12 she
was dating a friend of mine yeah she
still got nice too high tide titties oh
she did good stomach that was a loser oh
isn't that the story of everybody 20
years ago yeah and she called me one day
what if they got married no I don't know
what do you think my Sharon I don't know
what the [ __ ] to tell you yeah it's like
when they ask you
yeah what are you gonna do but they're
gonna get married the next week you can
never tell the truth
you gotta hedge your bets you went down
did she call me and I go no they're
gonna so she bugged me for two weeks and
she told me if she goes so many people
at my level like mid-level comics upper
level even you know headliners they
turned her down because nobody wants to
eat it on that show and the chances
you eating it or great you're in a
really bad situation
two minutes talk to the judges and then
two minutes a stand-up it's a tough set
but because I never watched the show and
I was sitting in my [ __ ] trailer with
no hope I'm like what do I have to lose
I'm already on the bottom I cannot go
any farther fall
[ __ ] yeah I'll do it if they'll take me
which I didn't think they would so
finally she goes no they're British they
already said your tapes they love you
come on and I did and I went in with an
airplane hangar it wouldn't Santa Monica
with just the head producer and the
sound person and the co-producer of
three people in the airplane hangar and
like this is great and then I did like
two minutes and then they go that's
great you have any more I go below I
prepare two minutes but I put time in
for laughs but you're the shittiest
audience I've ever had I mean it was
great and then I got on the show so and
how many levels did you have to go on
the show I made it like to the finals
how many weeks I was like took a year
takes a year's a page at all not a dime
not a dime okay
and we lived a hundred and five miles
from Hollywood so we were considered
local they had to pay our own motel when
we came in so I was sleeping on a lot of
couches so is Lou what god I can't
believe we didn't call you and ask to
say you remember 99 wheels of justice
what was that show on yeah yeah TNN
fifty wheels of justice and they shot a
San Diego and they gave me $65 per diem
I lived in Hollywood yeah they paid me
scale but they gave me a hotel yeah they
would give you a hotel nice what's the
rainiest for hotel now 150 yeah what
mother I'm like we should move I thought
about moving to a different trailer park
35 miles and Farah there south but but
it but in the very end of the finals
when you're at the Dolby and stuff they
put you up I think they put us with the
last two finals they didn't put us in LA
but the bottom line was I had I didn't
care because something used to being
poor forever god uh-oh I'm not getting
my $15 tonight kill me right so it
didn't matter to me about money because
we already know how to live on air so I
just
hope that it would work out and I did so
it was can you explain to people loving
something so much people don't have an
idea what it's like to love something so
much not because you want to be a star
yeah just because you want to be good at
something yes
you cut Netflix you cut the television
you sell your couch yeah and you're like
this is how I'm gonna live because it
really doesn't matter I'm just doing
comedy anyway like it doesn't matter it
doesn't something like something to get
twenty dollars some nights I'm gonna get
fifty dollars yeah there's some nights
I'm not gonna get dick yeah but I know
I'm doing three cents a night out of a
year I can afford an apartment you know
it's like once you do caught you do it
and then you go oh I know what I need to
do yeah this is what needs to be done if
I want to do this oh you want to start
them seen on the road you're getting 250
a week in the hotel that car better be
comfortable yeah you better know how to
take a shower behind the thing and
[ __ ] and the gas station and you know
these are the things you gotta learn how
to sneak into a hotel and jump in their
pool that's good enough I'll put some
gel in my head I'll do a show sometimes
you can't take a shower you just got to
shoot the pool free breakfast yeah
please not know how many times I pulled
up behind a hotel and just went to sleep
and nobody even bothered you but people
really don't understand the concept of
loving something that you know think
right now that I know for a fact there's
no money in coming mm-hmm do I want to
do comedy yes locally mm-hmm once this
area opens up again yeah I'm gonna be a
demon doing comedy I got I did love
though when I got that room at Las Vegas
at the Kimmel room that residency and
that was like so much fun and then I
loved seeing that gigantic Joey Diaz
billboard in Las Vegas I mean there is I
was there when you yeah you were there
when I was there only on Tuesday nights
and so I didn't get to see you but I saw
your billboard and I was so [ __ ] a
treasure Allen yeah I was supposed to be
in Treasure Island in two weeks yeah
I was [ __ ] we left Lou's guitar in
Lewis piano in the Kimmel room on
because we were coming back the next
Tuesday it's been there for four months
yeah you know I was on Rogan sting on
Saturday night and I'm like you know I
gotta be honest with you people the
first three months as I thank God to go
out at night know ya do all this [ __ ]
anyway thank God we were [ __ ] my thing
and I'm a comic goin to the comedy store
57 okay you forget it's my pants every
30 minutes I can't see at night you know
how many things are moving quickly I'm a
down in here the cocaine tooth is back
as it shipped that was the cocaine
twosome My Name Is Earl
look at that you say my name is Earl
that's not a problem that was the
cocaine to at the end when I saw it on
TV I was so embarrassed I went to a
doctor the next day and he goes it was
the day before Christmas I go you gotta
fix this I can't walk around with this
crackin he goes what are you guys the
house I go like 500 on just bring it in
he was not only do a few for Christmas
he goes it's only gonna last three as
well it lasted 13 nice but it fell off
the other night so you can't I talk to
my girl she's like you know give us a
few weeks because right now that this is
that's all now take that we just got a
guy in Mexico for you
we Carly's Oh Luis an ex-felon and he
could go you went what do you know you
get a passport you know anyway yes you
can you know what you cannot get is a
personnel award oh forget it before oh
well never mind
besides it's awful nobody's gonna drive
six hours to the dentist but us yeah no
no I'm not going to Mexico I'm sorry no
it's not a good idea
yeah no I
I got an Armenian that doubles the
bodyshop they sprayed Windex on his face
before they operated so that it I would
not recommend it
they sprayed Windex around the chair I
saw yeah you know it's like this cold
good test this Cobra tested Dodger
Stadium you see the lines why would you
go there
why would you go there do you know what
okay again I got a GED one of the odds
is the testing five thousand people a
day are those people doctors or they
just just the average of human and I
don't want to say this word but just
with human stupidity there's so much
human error then I put Vickie barber wax
tube into Lisa I had bags you know
there's so many people that you there's
four cars at one time you know hum how
much error how much room for error do
you have you want to get tested Kovac
pay the doctor get a blood testing you
got the antibodies but for you to put a
[ __ ] swab and your nose especially me
and a little look they put the swab and
you knows what I gotta get back I got
far like I told the other night listen I
started with THC crystal which is angel
dust it's animal tranquilizer
then I moved on to cocaine some heroin
along the way then you go down on women
you sniff that [ __ ] that gives you
something you know god forbid them from
behind you get that [ __ ] bust when
you first open up the ass it gives you
like that [ __ ] dust and under the
nose and then you know I got a smelled
Newark you know I'm saying like you ever
drive through Newark once you have all
that [ __ ] in your nose no test is gonna
come back negative
I'm coming back positive for something
yeah now what happens if they [ __ ] that
test up and they call Vic Ingo you just
[ __ ] up what are you talking about you
got everything in your nose cuz you know
coke can we got hair Serrano's do we not
if you got hairs in your nose you got
boards in your [ __ ] nose so [ __ ] went
into those [ __ ] pores
I trust one of those wabi-sabi Testament
if you come to me with a swabbie Dobby
test I don't want it
let's call me the night before I prepare
mentally I'll give me the blood
everything else is background [ __ ]
music
you got a piss test for it you gotta
have a piss test for it yeah it should
come out of your saliva test something
but yeah I want the blood let's be
certain what [ __ ] around my daughter
Lily's a scientist she's a
biostatistician and their company in
Carlsbad just for a little company 14
trials are going on right now for
testing so I mean there's just there's
going to be a home test soon I mean it's
sooner than ever because what she told
me and everyone knows is that they have
literally said there is no more
regulation we could do whatever we want
as fast as we want so it is gonna move
faster than it's ever moved before and
there's so many more companies and and
people on it there's think it will
happen it's just not going to be even as
fast as it is with all the populations
so big it's still gonna be slow but it's
going to happen home tests are gonna
happen soon and I mean I think because
the home trust I'm not sitting them down
they close the Dodger Stadium testing
facility well I love you know there's
the Dodger than that okay they were
practicing to have a major league
baseball team to generate millions of
dollars for this economy now you want to
sit out here with your covered fill car
ten hours where you [ __ ] ugly family
breathing over there I'm gonna get Kovac
and then it's coming out of the [ __ ]
vents and the guy next year that poor
[ __ ] Chinese guy that's getting
tortured he's not even Chinese he's like
from [ __ ] on congas um so he's
getting eggs thrown at his house he has
him more than anybody you know and also
he's sitting there you [ __ ] blowing
the window he'll get the air out he
lowers his the vid goes in his [ __ ]
car you can't you gotta wear a mask in
those things and it's not be like a
hundred people it's you know everybody
blame the protest there's a thousand
things I blamed you know there's a sad
day three people tested positive from a
flight on Delta Oh right after the
[ __ ] flight you know you can't do any
of this what about the covered parties
what well I couldn't believe I heard
about that I wish I could [ __ ] get a
room that would be such a great business
to get Cova dust and Mike yeah like
remember uh what's the [ __ ] black
Dracula space
blade blade blade blade yeah [ __ ]
remember he went to the first party and
the things opened and blood came out
yeah everybody was dancing to the what
that's what to do yeah I would love to
have those parties I'm [ __ ] great at
that I'll read one little Hitler
manifestos I'll get one of those parties
I locked the doors and start spraying
that [ __ ] I'll get one of those
[ __ ] things yeah he's just spraying
[ __ ] covered dust in there and watch
him go down one by one one by one and
whoever gets the money now that kid died
playing the game you should get the
money
yeah he won he won they better
renegotiate what party he went it
because whoever gets the culvert first
wins
I guarantee somebody else got it first
and this guy took the bullet and as he
was dying he's like I better get my
money I even told the nurse got it you
know how can we also I got like $14,000
tied up and Delta tickets right now and
you yes and I have no idea what I love
in [ __ ] JetBlue tickets okay I got
you I'm gonna lose that I can't yeah I'm
not gonna fly in time to get I'm not
going to you're right I've got two
rounds with guts on JetBlue we've got to
get him to first class [ __ ] mint and
they're not gonna save her for you
they're gonna save it for like nine
months I I you know I love JetBlue yeah
a lot of people don't know this shit's
gone away I that's why all that
cancellation [ __ ] was so important
cancel it and get your money back now
before people start realizing what's
really happening it's like I can't
understand it why okay I was like six
months booked so I buy tickets in
advance because they're cheaper so I
lets tickets all bought and then Delta
goes well we're living to two years but
my contracts are all void why isn't my
contract with Delta void I don't want to
get on their plane because people are
getting sick uh it's just uh and what I
really want the money back I need it
everybody died means what listen they're
a showman I do this podcast one reason I
brought you on today for one reason
because I know you bring joy right now
people haven't
the hardest times in their life and I
could tell you this out their stories I
know personally Oh blow a pilot okay
I'll blow a pilot I'm offering to blow
any Delta pilot that's listening right
now listen to me yes I don't even think
nobody wants a blow job
would you take a blow job to my civilian
right you know okay I won't blow you
I will not blow that no-good dick in
your bloodstream or your nutsack now
you're nuts got covent oh now we have a
kids the kid's gonna be warm with cold
right from the gate the kids
asymptomatic he's born his eyes off [ __ ]
no I don't wanna see nobody I want
talking about it I was having some fun
with my wife my wife for a while for a
couple of weeks we were banging out cuz
I'm like you know you come in you piss
you got a covert on your hands thank God
I always wash my hands that's good
before I touch my dick yeah I've been
doing that since I was 18 once a year I
don't like my I don't even put my dick
in the toilet when I [ __ ] I [ __ ] up I'd
rather leave the stain I like a snail
then leave my nutsac I want my nutsack
and my dick to always be clean prepared
I don't want somebody to come back and
say I got a toothache so good you have
to be you know that's why that's why you
people listen here you have to wash your
[ __ ] hands before you touch your neck
if not the woman you love or the guy you
love is gonna get something one day he's
gonna come back with a [ __ ] cavity
and I don't know how I gotta wash your
[ __ ] hands before you touch your dick
yeah unbelievable how has life been
after this what is life treating you
like what do you feel like honestly the
very best thing was seeing my name at
the Comedy Store the same night your
name was up at the Comedy Store that
night was like the best night for me
getting back to the comedy store was the
best thing beyond anything else and then
just just the world that the tour the
touring headlining and oh my life
dreamed like I could do an hour and be a
good headliner and get people to laugh
for hour after hour and and the strength
it's like laying the brick and getting
that point where you really can lay a
good
and do fancy tricks my wife taped you
everyday I love that I would think I
watched but what I'm with you and I was
so [ __ ] proud of you like you said my
peers of my eyes I look for that [ __ ]
like I leave the house at night
wife's do karlie before I leave the
house at night I check Conan yeah I
checked Letterman I check everybody to
see from one of my friends you sound
great and I tape it and I sit there in
the next morning I wake up like a
[ __ ] fourteen-year-old kid who's
gonna get his dick sucked by the teacher
the first time right I wake up ready to
go and I put the special you know I put
your thing on TV and I'm [ __ ]
cheering for you thank you and six out
of ten times I'm very disappointed why
do you do that joke he's been doing that
joke for [ __ ] two years god damn it
you just [ __ ] it up you couldn't take
a sign out you know like I'm one of
those guys like I'm coaching them yeah
do the [ __ ] radiator joking they're
like well yeah and I'm like [ __ ]
getting pissed off with you you look
beautiful like you were comfortable
talking to the judges you [ __ ] they dug
yeah I'm like that's the comedy stuff
yeah it is my wife says you can't won
that that's the comment that is the
Comedy Store because this crazy takes
everything up it takes it takes you down
to be real especially the original room
you have to find you cannot be in there
and not any any bit of you that's not
real is like an x-ray machine so I feel
like that's what I was into so long and
so yeah being on that show is millions
of people watch that show like 13 14 15
million people a week watch that show
and so I had no idea of what that would
mean for my career and it's just I'm so
lucky and happy cuz I just kept hoping
that something would happen that I get
to keep doing stand-up and I didn't know
what it would be but I just hope that
something would happen and that's what
happened and I got could you be a road
warrior at this age then I was two years
and I know I came home like twice we
were after I mean yeah and it was in it
you know it's great it it is great as
long as you could do it it's great and I
have met so many wonderful people and
you know people took me on boat rides
and took me of their houses and fed me
and Lou and we had met great people and
it was so
fun and then it ended so fast and that's
okay
it happened for everyone and and maybe
it'll happen again and Vegas will come
back but whatever it is I got to do it
and I am so grateful I learned one thing
out of this quarantine in this situation
I'm okay though I'm lying to you if I'm
telling you I'm not having a hard time
some nights I had to stop doing the
animals because I was using them as a
crutch
you know you got nothing else well I got
no spot tonight as well start eating
edibles at 4:00 in the airplane and my
[ __ ] ate I'm a mess you know on the
couch so you know I said some things I
did some things that about calmly that
you know it was too much in my life I
didn't want that much in my life and now
I realize that was wrong you know I was
wrong and I'll tell you what man I hope
they do come up with a vaccine I hope
they make it that at least we could
perform in front of 200 people
mm-hmm otherwise I'll see you in the
alley 57 yeah so I just want to stay
healthy enough to do one you know wobble
like go to every [ __ ] small club from
Providence like I liked all those 280
clubs you know yeah that's my world
anything after that that theater world I
went on that was a great time but I got
to tell you something wasn't for me it's
not to feel what you want it wasn't for
me I realized that I remember realizing
it and going why do I keep booking
theaters and I remember I had either in
June was the last set of Cedars it was a
Cleveland Indianapolis run and I'm like
I don't give a [ __ ] what cuz you know in
April you know we didn't know about
Colvin we thought we were gonna be back
to work in June
dealers are gonna be back to get it and
I remember looking at that date going I
can't do it it was too much for me to
fly into a city I was flying into a city
Thursday I'm not complaining I had a
nice and easy this is as easy as could
be yeah I go to the best restaurant in
town well
well like local flavor yes like
somewhere local rustling I give a little
big tip I talk to the locals the show
has already sold out and I'm saying I
have to do nothing yeah I just wanted to
go meet some of the locals yeah and then
I went back to the hotel
Friday I get up I go to a kickboxing
school or something in the area and I
call them before I go to the gym I'd
smoke pot have a nice breakfast at the
hotel take a nap watch Marcos yeah and
then you do this little 8 o'clock show
of the theater you know and this
sold-out and after what you take some
pictures in your room my 10:30 11
o'clock yep
you know but this is what I didn't like
I had to be out of there by 10:00 and go
to another train station and it was
either a four-hour train a 3-hour and
sadly is your that day sadly Friday
night when you go on the road you can't
wait till the second show is over cuz
you got Twinkies
you got a [ __ ] pizza you've got
[ __ ] eight sleeping pills you got
edibles you got heroin
you got narcos you got The Godfather you
have so many things when you go back to
the alto why cuz you don't have to get
up on Saturday hello hello no radio and
said no radio on Saturday so I'm up to a
four [ __ ] around Friday nights right
texting whatever the [ __ ] you know then
Saturday you get up at 8 I would not
know even if I went to bed at 4 I get up
at 8 catch two eggs sunny-side up two
pieces of bacon two pieces of wheat
toast no butter eat it walk outside
smoke a [ __ ] joint go back to the
hotel room and that's why I sat till
about 5:00 4:30
I'd go to the gym get a little room
service because I'm not going lower at
6:00 like 6:00 I'm not going no and
everybody's got a piece of salmon right
everybody's got salmon so I need Sam go
to the club I rather do the clubs yeah I
was more comfortable in that clothes
they feel the room you feel yeah in the
theatre they're so far away you don't
have a dialogue boom baboom it's only
getting real it's great it's fun
it's a great experience to have well I'm
going back to Sweet Home Alabama yeah
I'm going back to the club you know
which ones I don't know we'll see which
ones open and what's left but that's how
I feel
you know really stuck with me from our
we had a Rudy Sarzo on wheeze an episode
and he said the thing that helped him in
life is to not look for happiness but to
look for peace and that sort of sounds
like what you're talking about joy
because you could everyone talking about
doing theaters and doing arenas but
you're just more peace comfortable they
listen it's all about your age and what
you've been through what you've seen
we've seen how many traumas come and go
yeah that had more things going on than
you and I have ever dreamed
yeah it disappeared itself on Facebook
they're selling real estate yeah they
just couldn't Florida no yeah this is
too much all right
you know this I always just think they
had sense this is too much this is you
know this the beginning of this is rough
the middle this is rough and guess when
it gets rougher once you're up there I
can't imagine Kevin Hart's life yeah
no wonder you flipped that [ __ ] car I
can't imagine yeah Dave Chappelle's life
you know right right yeah arenas fluffy
you know yeah that's not I love that
he's doing it yeah but you know why I
just want to go back to the club yeah
for real I wanna Lenny Bruce it yes I
wanna [ __ ] there's so talk to people
yes
that's what you're doing it for the
theater is like oh you're doing it for
this how many clubs do you go to to see
the staff mm-hmm right like the staff
and the wiseguy
yeah you does so naive hland yep the
staff is that the depth of the [ __ ]
West Palm Beach yeah
the staff is sweet down there you know
Tempe oh my god they couldn't be any
nicer yeah so you go you look forward to
all that yeah now we don't have dick
yeah I look forward to watching my goal
is not to watch jeopardy at 7:00 if
jeopardy comes on I'm at the wrong room
okay so this is it 10:00 to 7:00 I get
up and I
sometimes I cry then I call Lee and
torch him to make myself feel better
I talk Khali and Tom I'm gonna bring a
hooker to his house and so funny their
ass but I love that you said you already
forgot that you're a comic I mean it's
only been three or four months and we've
done it for every night I had a firm yet
because if not it would be too plain
yeah I guess it's just I had to forget
yes I had to forget this like getting
raped
we got raped I got [ __ ] raped man 29
years I was doing something the guy came
with a [ __ ] a woman dick yeah I
shoved up my water and a little ass
yeah and now not me but all my [ __ ]
friends are all stuck in an apartment
together every goddamned night and you
know I don't I wouldn't send the friend
of mine unless you're [ __ ] parent
dies you go on a plane right now that's
it if you call me you tell me you go on
a Disneyland I'm gonna take your phone
off my phone no you're right it is true
and it's just like I think you're right
though it's like you can't think about
it but I guess also think like oh maybe
maybe I was just pretending
anyway was all pretend it wasn't real no
was real it was [ __ ] real well now
what the prisoner was real yeah and the
certain that sentence I served and
[ __ ] calmly this has been real okay
grams yeah you know right we served this
was this different type of prison calmly
is a different type of prison because it
lives in your head guys yeah we live in
our heads
I don't need four bars to put me in
prison I could do it on my own if you
want I'll give you one of these these
are helping these ABX is not put you in
prison but yeah that's all you're a
comic you put ourselves mentally in
prison I'm not good enough that joke
sucks yeah I look like [ __ ] I don't know
why do this with every [ __ ] guy my 29
years every time I Drive to the comedy
store I'm a loser yes my mother sucks
can't believe she died yeah you know and
then you catch yourself by sunset you
like what those left of my 12 yeah I'm
headed to the world-famous my [ __ ] you
talking about I'm gonna go steal that
like [ __ ] what are you crazy
believing the house when I gotta go on
the road
I know what Thursday Oh
little Joey becomes the biggest [ __ ] you
have met in your life I lose things I
yell at my wife I don't know whether you
trying why should I charge and they
yours
you know right and then you get the you
like you get the uber you like okay yeah
this is what I do this is what I do you
get to the airport you cut to the phone
line right hey what's going on you go to
American Airlines they got the really
heavyset black sheet don't let you
upstairs
beautiful so I would flirt with a
constant is my girl oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and
she's how you doing sugar and you go you
know you know people at the airport
forget Burbank I got them on [ __ ]
speed down I do what I wanted Burbank
cuz I'm Monica SEALs life nice his
daughter runs Burbank Southwest ah all
you gotta do is go up there she gives
you like the [ __ ] handicap card you
get on the plane first I'm saying no
matter what you can have cat2 and that
[ __ ] you go come in okay take this take
this and next thing you know you walk on
the plane with a limping [ __ ] but yeah
[ __ ] if you gotta borrow your nephews
football helmet and walk in there yeah
listen if you're gonna get down we gotta
get down into the sunday back it we have
a fake service dog and they all know
it's in San Diego so they all just smile
and let us in but your ancestor so what
are you gonna do now what are we doing
now what's the name of the park
I started podcasters called big girls
don't cry are tools and it's on iTunes
and and do it live on YouTube okay on
Spotify that's why it's on Spotify so we
just have two episodes in and I sent
with my legs my legs apart because I
always spread my legs because I won't
sit well so I got a lot of complaints
the first week from my snatch but like
you said I'm just gonna put
advertisements down there from next
weekend tied them together because I was
so emotionally there you go clean it
I'll get the floss there that's right
Lou that's lose job and then the best
thing is you take those on the way you
sell them brand new but you also tell
them this I got the like right now you
get this to the rest all in two versions
the a conversion yeah and the regular
version tell them like
a short field I walk a mile in yeah I
know I'm saying what do you want to do
with those autograph those come
autograph this is next 420 there you go
if it would get a whiff of that monkey I
gotta get through this I'm not Joey just
say yes so listen there's a thousand
houses on the company that's it
that's it really is that's it you you're
such a personality you're such a
sweetheart
Joey you look like that this is a
natural for you you're gonna be doing
two of these a week Lou said you know
Vicky it's like you know you you're we
couldn't stay on the road forever this
might be a blessing I'm like you know it
could be a do and I'm with my friend
Amber Rose my best friend died of four
years ago Cyndi burns and she was
producer of funniest Housewives of
Orange County anyway she was great Joan
Rivers found her right before she died
and it was great and she was wonderful
and but her daughter amber is my co-host
and I love amber so it's really special
so it's really fun
Vicki man when I saw what was going on
with you I was very happy because
finally the good guys won you know
like I'm finally the good guys want no
we know who worked hard and who's put
their ass in the line that was
sacrificed
you know you lived in a trailer park
Vicki you sacrificed I mean I've been so
grateful but yeah I mean people dropped
off food sometimes and I was so
embarrassed like people are dropping off
food they know I would let it slip that
a job job got canceled I let it slip
with my friend and then I get home and
there's a bunch of bags of food from
Trader Joe's outside and I'm like [ __ ]
I'm such a [ __ ] loser I'm the worst
mother and then I went on the other hand
somebody loves me so much that they're
gonna drop off food for us so I was like
learn that kind of gratitude and that's
the the great thing about doing what you
love just jumping off that cliff and and
letting it happen and so people always
go like you've struggled you sacrificed
if I had kept my parents [ __ ] carpet
store like I was supposed to do and
being rich from that shitball life that
would have been suffering so I feel like
I haven't suffered I've been just so
happy poor but extremely happy [ __ ]
that [ __ ] happy yeah [ __ ] them right
yeah
money don't buy happiness and people
really
know that until they find happiness and
they see that what was all that fuss
about that's what people are saying
about kovat the lesson that other people
learn is that you will find that you do
not you will find happiness other than
on what you can [ __ ] buy at the mall
and the [ __ ] you can order you can find
happiness a whole different way and my
daughters are raised on air and I think
and their peers are lovely and wonderful
but my daughters with grit you know
because they had to and they were on
their own and they knew it so I think
that also children like just our world
was just becoming so bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye get get get get get anything of
my own ahead and so I mean I was like
jumping back down that train and that
I've not been on forever so I'm grateful
that that train is not there for me
right now and I think that's gonna be a
lesson for a lot of people don't that
that it's not about consuming it's about
loving people are having fun right now
yeah it's it's listen a lot of people
gonna get thrown out at the end of this
month there's gonna be a lot of pain
there's gotta be a lot of confusion and
this is why I do this podcast why so
weak looking for something alright I got
no tickets to sell yeah no there's
nothing yeah I do this because I want
people to know we're with them yeah well
with them we know what you're going
through a man and I have empathy for you
I wish I had a hundred million dollar
spotify deal just like to send all my
listeners a [ __ ] stimulus check no I
really would because they've been here
with us through all these years the only
stimulus I give him his love for them to
pass on absolutely not to be angry
there's no debtors prison can't put you
in jail for being in debt you've sucked
my dick you keep calling me I hang up on
you I don't give a [ __ ] and if I change
numbers you know Jesus
I've lived off robbing before and you
know what it's not bad no it's not bad
so they can't take away your dignity
they can't take away your soul you know
some girl call me although she goes I
sold my TV my stereo on my couch she's
having a hard time and my reply there
I've known of her so well and she's such
a decent girl she hasn't realized why
she's beating herself up to 100
and I said you haven't sold your soul
like most of these people in town and
you haven't sold you [ __ ] once you do
that that's when you got a problem yeah
but if you need to sell those two in
this [ __ ] town you're gonna be fine
so I knew you know and me whatever it's
true I thought you have to just
understand that the worst case is we end
up with a shopping cart we're still
gonna be all right
what's the little bit you know where and
if you know somebody who needs a bag of
rice and you have a big race you could
drop it off their house or like I have
an old neighbor in my trailer park and
she's French
and she's I know she's low on money and
low on wine so I buy really cheap
bottles of wine for me that's my drink
and I'll give her an extra bottle for $2
and it's like just like if you know if
you suspect a friend needs some food I
can tell you I'm not that I probably do
it better if I didn't take the free food
should've got hungry more but if you do
know somebody who needs a little
something there's nothing nothing wrong
with topping off the bag of rice for bag
of beans I mean especially now just keep
your eyes open who might need a little
something it's not like you can give a
bunch of money we don't have it but you
can give somebody Kovac and it's my
bread Vicki that was that's what this is
all about is empathy right now
yeah you know you go on social media
that's hate a nay nay nay nay nay
this is empathy man this is you know
somebody told me tell you can I get dice
on the show and and to prove that well
you people can't attack you no more for
saying what you're saying if you keep
attacking all they want I'm gonna keep
saying what the [ __ ] I'm saying until
they throw me under the jail or six feet
under so at this point you just suck my
dick
yes I'm what days do you release your
podcast on Thursdays Thursdays yes I
want you to download what's the name of
it big girls don't cry you will not I
want you to follow her journey she's
gonna take you on a [ __ ] great
journey because she's taking me on a
journey thing I realized something today
I realized why I quit doing coke and
stuck with it
Maryland did cut a deal with me right on
Thank You Marilyn you sweet girl she did
cut a deal for me I think she's been
watching over me really strong me too I
feel it I light a candle one day my
shiver her Mitzi yeah so people have no
idea
yeah really a boy yeah I love you love
you Joey
thank you congratulations I love you
thank you for cracking ly you showed
them calmly 101 by saying his name wrong
that's thank God you were playing the
piano the whole audience would I had
them fracture for me thank you guys for
doing a show I enjoyed so much it makes
my week so much better please
this is what we do here real quickly
what's the website Viki Oh Big E Barbra
a comedy right write it down marble that
comedy have I ever told you not to watch
son watch this woman this woman is
amazing
she's my comedy sister and that's it we
got no date super month nobody's
promoting dick all we're promoting is
love yet but before I leave let me talk
to you about some stamps.com skip the
line print postage 24/7 everybody's
avoiding crowds right now people
coughing people with math nothing nobody
wants to go to the post office right
print postage at home and skip the lines
which stamps calm plus you saved money
on discounts you can't even get at the
post office and now stamps calm is
working with UPS so you get discounts up
to 62% like I told you the beginning of
the show my wife lives upstairs calm
this has been for eight years we've been
working with stamp calm any letter any
size package going anywhere in the world
right from your crowd couch crouch right
from your couch and the best part is the
mailman will come and pick it up no
contract required it's that simple you
also get great discounts you get five
cents off every first-class stamp and up
to 62 off percent of shipping save up to
62 percent on UPS rates Plus never pay
residential surcharges again listen my
brothers stamps.com is a no-brainer
especially now you're saving time you're
saving money and you're keeping it safe
which is the most important thing so
right now today grab a pen
you think on a special offer for the
church family they got a four-week trial
plus free postage and
digital scale no one long-term
commitments poor contracts it's very
easy just go to stamps comm click on the
microphone on top of the homepage and
press in church CH you are CH that
stamps comm press in church and that
sitting that's at Lu thank you very much
for driving Vicky bar black you look
more beautiful than ever
Lisa I Anna I love you I hope you enjoy
that Cuban sandwich and you guys I'll
see you Wednesday morning ready to take
top Magoo [ __ ] listen stay safe
watch with you what's going on out there
I saw a [ __ ] guy beat up a hooker at
9:30 in the morning from the CVS of
Lankershim the other morning because she
stole his wallet and I got my con I took
off and people were like why did you
tape it because there's a lot of guns
going off so you see something that
doesn't look right guys do me a favor
turn around and walk away don't take
your [ __ ] camera I don't want you to
get shot mind your [ __ ] business
you're not Jimmy Olsen you're not a
reporter
turn around and walk away okay have a
great day today Monday I love you
[ __ ] stay black Lee kick this
[ __ ] meal
[Music]